la voilà la voilà enfin cette réforme
c'est très forme attendue si nécessaire
pressante si urgente mais si longtemps
repoussé la voilà enfin reprise par le
gouvernement cette proposition
sénatoriale renouvelée année après année
voter revotez contre la vie de ce
gouvernement
alors pourquoi pourquoi le gouvernement
n'a-t-il donc pas jugé bon de se rallier
dès 2018 au recommandations du Sénat la
pente serait moins raide le déficit
moins abyssal que de temps perdu que de
temps perdu néanmoins
néanmoins les faits sont là
messieurs les ministres il n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
les mesures de redressement des comptes
de la bronche vieillesse sont plus que
jamais impératifs madame la rapporteur
général c'est la raison pour laquelle la
Commission approuve les dispositions
d'âge de l'article 7
face à l'accélération de l'allongement
de la durée d'assurance requise pour le
taux plein 43 ans voté par la gauche de
cette hémicycle
cet article 7 reprend le relèvement de
l'âge à 64 ans proposé par la droite de
cette émission
sachez sachez que nous serons quand même
toujours attentifs au rendement des
mesures en ce qui concerne l'article 8
comme je le soulignais en novembre
dernier pour la quatrième fois mes chers
collègues il est nécessaire que ces
mesures ne pénalisent pas les
travailleurs les plus fragiles que
soient prises en compte les spécificités
de carrière différentes aussi aussi la
commission vous propose d'améliorer
l'article 8 qui aménage les différents
dispositifs de retraite
anticipées de façon à accorder une
surcote de 5% aux assurés ayant obtenu
au moins un trimestre de majoration au
titre de la maternité de l'adoption ou
de l'éducation et arriver à une carrière
complète pour qu'elle soit 64 ans c'est
bénéficiaires puissent disposer d'une
surcote
cette surcote est quand même un élément
tout à fait déterminant qui permet
d'améliorer les pensions des mers de
famille et de réduire l'écart de pension
entre les hommes et les femmes
[Musique]